aquí tenemos dos figuras y queremos
pensar en cuánto espacio ocupan estas
figuras en la pantalla ya este concepto
de cuánto espacio ocupa una figura sobre
una superficie plana se le conoce como
área lo voy a poner aquí arriba
muy bien ahora a simple vista parece ser
que la figura de la derecha ocupa más
espacio que la figura de la izquierda
pero que tanto más espacio ocupa bueno
pues para responder esa pregunta sería
bueno tener alguna forma de medir el
área y para medir el área hay varias
formas de hacerlo una forma de hacerlo
es pensar en lo siguiente lo que podemos
hacer es tomar un cuadrado déjame tomar
este cuadrado ya este cuadrado lo vamos
a pensar como la unidad de área y es una
unidad de área porque cada uno de sus
lados va a medir una unidad de distancia
entonces aquí este lado va a medir una
unidad unidad
y este lado de acá también va a medir
una unidad vale un
unidad unidad y como es un cuadrado de
una unidad por una unidad del área que
ocupa este este cuadrado le vamos a
llamar una unidad unidad
cuadrada
cuadrada cuadrada muy bien entonces una
forma de saber que tanto espacio ocupan
estas figuras es ver cuántas de estas
unidades cuadradas caben dentro esto es
que no se salgan de la figura y además
que no se encimen vale entonces vamos a
utilizar esa idea para medir el área de
estas dos figuras déjame empezar con la
figura de la izquierda
voy a poner aquí un cuadrado entonces va
uno otro más dos otro más tres
todavía caben otros dos cuatro y uno más
dan 55
excelente déjame volverlos a volverlos a
contar marcando los son 1 2 3 4 5 si
quisiéramos pues podemos aquí dividirlos
para ver que realmente realmente no se
enciman vale algo de este estilo
entonces como caben cinco de estos
cuadrados en esta figura vamos a decir
que el área de esta figura del área de
la figura azul lo voy a poner aquí el
área
es de 55 unidades unidades
cuadradas
muy bien vamos a hacer exactamente lo
mismo con la figura de la derecha en la
figura de la derecha podemos poner ahí
un cuadrado ahí va uno otro más
1 + 3
vamos a poner otro 5
otro por acá 6
otro más 7
8 ya casi terminamos 9 9 y 10 excelente
entonces en esta figura de la derecha en
esta figura de la derecha caben
dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho
nueve diez cuadrados unitarios y por lo
tanto el área el área de esa figura el
área
es de 10 unidades unidades
cuadradas
gradas
cual
gradas muy bien entonces como en la
figura de la izquierda caben cinco
cuadrados cuadrados unitarios de lados
una unidad decimos que su área es de
cinco unidades cuadradas y en la de la
derecha caben diez y por lo tanto su
área es de 10 unidades cuadradas y estas
unidades que tienen los lados del
cuadrado pues después podemos podemos
pedir que sean otra cosa podemos pedir
que sean centímetros metros o pulgadas y
entonces la unidad sería una pulgada
cuadrada por ejemplo o un metro cuadrado
muy bien entonces usando esta idea para
medir el área tenemos que la figura de
la izquierda tiene cinco unidades
cuadradas y la de la derecha tiene 10
unidades cuadradas la figura de la
derecha ocupa el doble de área en la
pantalla que la de la izquierda